FEBRUARY TWO FOUR TWENTY TWENTY
TWO IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER. AND
AS A FIRST ORDER BUSINESS I JUST
WANTED KNOWLEDGE AND WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE FONG OF THE
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY WHO JOINS US
ON THIS PANEL. FOR THE WORK OF
RULES SO WELCOME HERE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG. ON PLEASE BE
ADVISED THAT AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDINGS BEING MADE OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDING AND HAS ALSO BEEN
TELEVISED. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
ATTENDING THIS HEARING MUST WEAR
A MASK AT ALL TIMES. ATTENDEES
MUST ALSO REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT THIS HEARING. VIOLATION
OF THE RULES WERE SUBJECTED
INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. ON MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM BENNETT.
FLORA FONG. GIPSON HERE LEE YEAH
MAIENSCHEIN. MATHIS YOUR RUBIO
THE ABUJA HERE. ARMS YOU HAVE A
QUORUM HAVE A CAN CHEN IS OUR
MOST ANNIKA AGENDA. OVER MISTER
SECONDED- RUBIO ARMED AND
RESEARCH SERVICE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY I COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
BENNETT BENNETT HIGH FLORA FONG
FONG AYE GIPSON- GIPSON HI LI LI
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS MATHIS AYE RUBIO. RUBIO
HI VOEVODA VENTURA HIGH MOTION
PASSES THE MOTION PASSED OF
COLLEAGUES I. THINK WE'RE BEING
HERE I WILL REMAIN FOR. JOINT.
THEY WERE MORNING.
THIS RULES
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.